Tiffany says, "Why do you like lap dances
so much?"
"Okay.
In 2007, there was a movie called Grindhouse.
And in the trailer quentin tarantino himself
promised us a lap dance.
So I went to see that movie--all 10 hours
and 47 minutes of it--and there was no lap
dance anywhere.
So, then flash forward, I get the DVD with
my buddy and we watch the 6 hour director's
cut and lo and behold, there's the lap dance
that we'd been promised in the original trailer.
It made me wonder how many other movies that
that happened in, where they film a lap dance
and then they just cut it before it ends up,
you know, hitting the theaters.
I've gotten really good at spotting those
moments where it's obvious they filmed one
and it just didn't make the final cut.
"Why don't you stop doing the conversation
videos and other bullsh*t and just do more
sins videos?"
Alright.
I'm gonna assume just by asking that you've
never made a sins video, but whatever.
Let's forget for a second that most people
who watch the conversation videos actually
enjoy them.
Um.
Let's throw that aside.
What you're talking about is a time difference.
It takes way longer to make a sins video than
it does a conversation video.
It's like comparing the Grand Canyon to your
vagina.
It's like saying "Should I cook myself some
dinner, or should I build a log cabin with
my bare hands from scratch?"
Doing a conversation video in no way keeps
us from doing a sins video.
What keeps us from doing a second sins video
is that they take for f*cking ever.
It's time we're happy to spend... weekly.
But, you know, maybe just watch the sins videos
once a week and go about your life.
There's this new tool YouTube just put out
actually, it's called Not Watching Videos
That You Don't Like.
You should check it out.
"How many people are there behind Cinema Sins?"
Okay, this one, I'm glad we can clear up.
cinema Sins is two people.
But not you and me.
Right, not you and I.
You and I should be considered, like, one
entity.
Along with any other uses you see running
around here.
Right.
Like, the other guy has never been on camera,
but he's been part of the writing and shooting,
and editing since the beginning of Cinema
Sins.
He's like Teller.
Well, Teller appears on camera.
He's just silent.
So it's not exactly the best analogy.
It's a fine analogy, alright?
Everybody knew what I mean.
There's another guy, and he's mysterious.
How is he mysterious.
In ways!
"Will you have sex with me?"
Well, I don't know you, but sure.
Wait, is she hot?
Well, I don't know, dude, she didn't send
a picture.
It's just an email.
I don't even know if it's a girl.
Hmm.
I'll have to take my chances.